dan is in New York hey Dan welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave thanks for
your time
certainly how can I help sir so Dave I'm
32
I'm debt free I have a six month
emergency fund all there I'm putting a
little over 15% to retirement I feel
very good about that
and over the last three years I spent
maybe $75,000 in rent in a high cost of
living area so as of the 1st of
September I've relocated to my hometown
I put a 60-day self-imposed limit my my
folks are kind enough to let me kind of
crash here for two months but any more
than that I just won't be comfortable I
think I'm currently looking for a place
to live I'm trying to between a home and
an apartment now I do have quite a bit
of money stay for a down payment how
much what around 1780 thousand
where to go what do you make a year I
make what this Cheryl attracts about 1
in D good for you what do you do I work
in software engineering excellent
excellent
ok yeah so the town you're in is what
sighs now the town I'm moving back to is
very small so I'm lucky enough to be
able to work remote and my money will go
very far here um but you know I I've
been following your steps for about
three years now and I am terrified of
debt including a mortgage so I guess my
question is the first question is what
do I stick it out for another 2 or 3
years so I can buy a home and tasks but
in doing so I might spend another 30,000
in rent let's say and and if I bought a
house today I'm confident I could
probably have it paid off in maybe two
to three years right and the other
question is when the time comes whether
I buy today or in two years I'm really
struggling with parting with my money I
spent three years building this
stockpile of cash and you know there's
an emotional attachment to it yeah
that's a wonderfully healthy thing it's
interesting when we spend actual money
instead of borrowed money that it's
harder to do it's true for all of us I
mean when you borrow money it's just
like you know sign your signature and
like monopoly money it's not real
it's fake you know that's part of the
student loan crisis you know it doesn't
even feel like it's real oh I'll never
pay this back I'm not worried about it
whew you know and so the good news is is
you are struggling because you've got
this connection you've made it says hey
this was hard to put 80 thousand dollars
away it'd be hard to pay off a house in
two years but really only money's only
good for three things and you ought to
always be doing all three
you ought to a be enjoying it be
investing it and see giving it away with
outrageous generosity you ought to
always have some of those three in your
budget and in your case you make a lot
of money you're in a low cost of living
situation now in a small town and so I
think for today in the next 60 days I
don't think you're gonna be emotionally
excited about buying a house the guy I'm
talking to right now is not and I said
so you know but I might give myself a
self-imposed limit and say I'm gonna
rent for six months during that six
months I'm gonna get really comfortable
with the idea that real estate is also
an investment not having a rent payment
is a very nice thing and so getting a
house that you pay for are almost pay
for and pay it off very quickly is a
wonderful financial goal because that
you know as long as that little town is
doing okay financially economically and
that house is gonna go up in value and
someday if you want to sell it you can
sell it don't buy too much house don't
buy the biggest house in the entire town
or something like that
don't buy some weird house that you
can't sell but buy something that's
gonna go up in value and that has a
market when you do get ready to turn it
someday and look at it as an investment
look at it as a part of your financial
growth and that'll help you turn loose
of it because the good news is you're
not consuming the money you're not
buying an $80,000 cruise around the
world that when you get done the money
has just disappeared
that's consumption consumption is not
evil but this is not consumption or
talking about this is investing meaning
that if you had a bad situation you
could put the house up for sale sell it
get your money back out and then some so
it is an investment and investing is
different than consuming for me
investing and giving are easier than
consumption today my consumption I limit
to a small percentage although a small
percentage of my world is wonderful so
but I we limit it we limit our lifestyle
to a percentage of our income and
certainly a percentage of our net worth
and the rest of it is investing in
generosity because we get a bigger high
out of changing our family tree changing
the next generation and changing other
people's lives with generosity than we
do just behind stuff I mean we got a lot
of stuff we got nice stuff I'm not
complaining it's not like we live
Spartan we don't a Spartan we live very
luxurious but still even having done
that it's a very small percentage of our
world so I would be more concerned
giving that hard-earned money to
consumption than I would do investing or
to generosity because both of those are
a type of investing hey good questions a
good discussion it's a healthy thing
you're doing